you've got a charcuterie plate for your  cocktail party you have real earthy  flavor some saltiness from the meat some  peppercorns and of course some mustard  to spice it up it's a real statement on  the palate so for our cocktail I suggest  a classic the gin and tonic first we  make our cocktail will load our elastics  and ice and one and a half ounces of  Bombay Sapphire piece pop off with some  tonic give that a whirl and then garnish  with some lime  he performs  garnish with lemongrass so there you go  a new take on a gin and tonic serve  these two together and your cocktail  parties off to a great start there's  more cocktail videos like this on the GT  chap